all right guys this is a very important
video i want to talk about the
absolute most important thing you can do
to prevent cancer
fasting fasting is
hands down the most important thing to
do if you want to prevent cancer
and if you have cancer you need to be
doing fasting
cancer is the second leading cause of
death
so this is the protocol that i would
recommend
for someone that is interested in
preventing cancer
let's say for example your family has
cancer
or your health is poor or you just want
to
prevent cancer and you want to do
something about it i would recommend
start on omed immediately that means
one meal a day okay so you're only going
to eat one meal a day in fact
i recommend most people do all that
it's extremely easy to do
you're going to save a lot of money but
it's very very powerful
to improve your health which i'm going
to get to in a minute
so i would do omit on a regular basis
yeah and i recommend you do 48 hour fast
weekly now this is really good
to do if you have extra weight to lose
to one and a half teaspoons of sea salt
every single day very important
b vitamins and trace minerals so i put a
link down below if you want more data on
that but that
protocol would be very very important if
you want to take it to the next level
and
really help your immune system every
month
you would do a seven day fast now you
might
be freaked out to do that well fast as
long as you can maybe it's going to be
three days
maybe four days and maybe you have to
build up to a seven day fast but
if you did that you would put yourself
in really
good shape to prevent cancer so what i'm
talking about is regular intermittent
fasting
and periodic prolonged fasting
one video i did on the gentleman that
had cancer stage four
cancer okay he did some serious fasting
and he was expected to die within a
month
it's been two years he's doing great
his doctor can't find any cancer he did
a lot of fasting
he did more intense fasting than what
i'm talking about
but what i'm talking about is how to
prevent
cancer okay so i'm not primarily talking
about people who already have cancer
all right let's talk about why fasting
would help prevent cancer
first off it will help stop
mtor okay what is mtor mtor is something
in your body
that allows things to grow okay it
creates an anabolic effect
so when you fast you turn off
that effect so you can actually greatly
inhibit the growth of anything in your
body
okay it also decreases igf which is
another growth factor
so you're shutting down mtor and igf
so that right there is a powerful effect
on cancer
number two autophagy autophagy is a
condition where your body is recycling
the old damaged
junk okay let's say your mitochondria
are damaged or you have dead red blood
cells your body is going to actually
clean
all that up and since cancer originates
with
damaged mitochondria if you can clean
that
up there's not enough damaged
mitochondria
to turn into cancer which then these
cancer cells
become immortal which kind of sucks
because
your cells have a time limit but cancer
cells can live
forever all right number three you
actually generate
brand new stem cells for your immune
system
you're actually building a new immune
system and guess what your immune system
not only fights pathogens
it kills cancer it kills cancer cells on
a regular basis
so if you have a powerful strong immune
system you are very
protected number four fasting drops
inflammation
what you have to realize is that when
you have a metastasis
or a spreading of cancer guess where it
spreads into
areas of inflammation interesting even
areas of old injury
so by doing fasting you just drop
inflammation all right number five and
this pretty much
pertains to someone that has cancer and
is on chemotherapy let's say
they decide to do chemotherapy or
radiation therapy
fasting increases resistance for your
normal cells
when they're exposed to chemotherapy and
radiation incredible but
the cancer cells don't get that
resistance
they're more sensitized to chemotherapy
and radiation therapy interesting all
right so
what if you already have cancer okay i'm
not going to do a whole video on that
but i want to give you some tips
on some natural things that i would
recommend
and my disclaimer is i'm not telling you
this is going to cure anything check
with your doctor before taking anything
okay alpha lipoic acid
0.4 to 0.8 grams per day
you start off small amounts and you
gradually
increase over two to three weeks
okay next remedy would be garcinia
another name for garcinia is
hydroxycitrate
between 1.2 to 3 grams
start off with 1.2 gradually increase to
3 grams
over to three weeks this is per day
next remedy is red algae okay
eight grams per day next remedy is black
seed oil
you can get in 500 milligrams twice a
day
consume a lot of garlic if you can't eat
garlic take them in tablets
a lot of garlic is very very important
next remedy is green tea
you can also get this as a supplement or
consume it through the day
and lastly you want to consume a lot of
cruciferous vegetables
the broccoli sprouts would be very very
important
as well because it's a very small amount
of those broccoli sprouts
equal a tremendous amount of adult
broccoli
all right guys thanks for watching hey
before you go real quick
i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i
want you to take it
and here's why here's you
here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course
will show you how to bulletproof
yourself and so you can tolerate and
resist
your environment much better by
strengthening
your own immune system i put a link down
in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today